what's up guys so today we're going to
be unboxing something that i'm not even
sure if it's going to be good i have
absolutely no idea if it sucks or maybe
it's going to be the coolest thing ever
it's this really tiny
cube mobile projector here's what's
included in the box this showed up as a
recommended item on
amazon
so i don't know let's let's let's try it
out i was like yeah sure you're right
amazon how did you know that i needed a
mobile projector
i don't do you i mean maybe
[Music]
it's like the size of a gopro great
packaging super cute
it is
it is an actual cube
it's the size of two gopros actually
because it's a cube
maybe almost three gopros one two three
three pros
i can actually tell you how many one
two
two and a half gopro hero4s charge reset
power headphones microsd
okay so we've got a lot of items
i feel like this
is an excessively large remote control
for such a tiny little item just my
thought
power adapter
so it looks like this is the base of the
tripod so you stick yeah you just stick
it right in here this is just like one
of those basic little tripods that they
have everywhere
screw it in here
lots of usb
things
so it has like a little micro sd card
slot on it all right i hope there's some
files on here i just took it out of my
gopro and i'm gonna just
kind of hope for the best really power
on
[Music]
whoa
some things are happening some things
are happening
okay this is great
so now i just gotta focus it see here's
the problem it looks like it's
flickering on my screen because i
believe i'm shooting in 60 frames a
second because it's not flickering in
real life is there no battery in this
cause
hey dog we're doing some things
okay there's a battery great
okay it says aim it to the back of the
device
so here i am back here
yeah it works
video
i don't think there's any files on this
card okay we've got a few options now i
got this
at the apple store you can get it on
amazon as well you just click the
different bundle so this will allow you
to plug in your phone
and turn it into hdmi so i can plug this
into here
and this is really bright but we're
going to get this to work
nope
[Music]
it doesn't give me the large version of
the hdmi so what the hell do you want me
to do did i drop one
is that what the dog took
he
he stole my hdmi
you stole my hdmi
[Applause]
that's why i was having problems
all right so we'll just plug this in
[Applause]
dog
there's my phone
it's working
now the battery died
oh god let's try again
look at it
it looks like a monster let me find some
content
on my phone so it's got a little audio
out port on the back so i'm not sure
let's see
no why'd you turn off
oh my god
okay
here we go
oh boy
clearly this is the ideal situation
it's not but we're going to make it work
for the sake of finishing this video
there we go
why are you doing this for me
you're really fussing me up how do i
know this is a charge if you want to
freaking charge it like are you charging
are you not targeting
i'm not sure if this is user error
or item error
i think you use your air
[Music]
you're making me very very mad
okay
[Music]
yes yes okay things are happening
there's a little red light on the side
which means it's powering
so clearly it's user error
don't you turn off don't you dare
don't you dare
[Music]
it's
working out
here's the thing the audio kind of sucks
on the cube itself i mean it's not bad
all things considered but it does have a
little
uh headphone jack so what you can do is
get something like this
like one of the bows which is
needs charge god my life is just
not working out for this video today
i can't find the charger so what i'm
saying is you can plug in an external
speaker or anything else that you have
you could if you have sonos you could
also connect this to that so you could
have pretty much
audio wherever you have your sonos
connected
it does flicker here but in real life
it's not flickering it actually looks
really good
oh i like it
i'm not putting this on what are you you
can't back out i am not gonna wear two
dresses in the span of like three weeks
on youtube so here's the thing